how is your boyfriend he's great
[Music]
so my name is Ben and I was together
with Linda for a couple months I'm doing
this just because I like doing weird
things I I don't know why I'm doing this
I think my ex is great
she's great you know she's so she's
really sweet I'm Alex and I was dumped
hard and my name is Whitney and I was
with my significant other for six months
and I dumped him so the way she broke up
with me was she said that she just
wanted to be friends I feel like I need
to clear the air a little bit because I
think I was made out to be a villain so
I made this song called let's just be
friends and put it in a music video that
I made on YouTube this freakin music
video about me it was really cathartic
actually to make that video that kind of
rubbed me the wrong way but you know
good for him I watched it kind of catchy
I'll be the littles doing thank you
you're welcome
[Music]
yeah it's like survivor Wednesday's
should I like embrace do you want to
like actually like just do it just do it
I feel like we never did this when we
dated nothing yeah you're right
how is your boyfriend he's great
this is gonna be awkward to have him
watch sorry about this I don't
do you remember what we fought about
what started up nope don't remember we
fought over a lightbulb and I wanted it
I want is a delightful that was hanging
from the ceiling and I wanted it off and
you were like no I like that and I was
like I feel really insecurity like why
do you feel insecure and I was like
because I feel like you don't want me
here and we're like you're like I don't
want to be in a relationship and I was
like that's what I thought
I would have broken up with me if I had
been you back then are you still take a
wish okay yeah sorry I'm sorry
was I rebound yeah definitely but I
rebounded after you and that was like oh
[ __ ] show I ain't watch handle and you
can handle it I'm sorry did you regret
breaking up with me for a little bit
yeah I did
well like I had let a good thing go a
compliment for this lovely gentleman he
makes me laugh very hard and it's days I
remember I didn't like the sweater you
were on our second date but I was like
whatever that's okay and then later you
blue one with the column I love that
sweater
you're very unique and I have not met
too many people like you it just looks
kind of like pretentious oh it feels so
good to say better you so good I'd hate
that sweater I'm sort of sorry
that I went down the way did but I'm
glad you got success from your music
video you know what we wouldn't have
found two new people exactly happy
exactly see it just that's nice
some things aren't just meant to be yeah
you know it wasn't as bad as I thought
it would think it was it's kind of nice
felt good to reconnect that was not as
bad as I anticipated
yeah didn't hurt but that was fun this
is fine salt that weird hey there you go
high five
that's nice see we can high-five now we
can do that too you do some cuddling you
get a high-five out of it who doesn't
love a high-five all right sure yeah
okay yeah that was two in a row what's
wrong with that
oh why it's just a high-five we're good
see we're fine cuddle but be careful
cuddle with protection use condoms come
on that kind of sex with exes